[Aplausos]
yo quiero hablar de la historia de
américa
qué es una cosa bastante simple bastante
sencillo
la historia de américa se puede dividir
en cuatro partes
la primera fue españa
300 años
empezó con colom y terminó el 21 de
octubre de 1805 al mediodía
una cosa no fácil de pensar que la
historia cambia en un día pero a veces
los procesos de cambios que se van dando
hay un día en que se derrama el vaso y
que bueno ese día se cambia
españa hizo de américa un monopolio
absoluto a que no podía venir nadie que
no fuera español e inclusive ni siquiera
todos los españoles por ejemplo los
catalanes no podíamos venir hasta el
1800 nos pasamos 300 años no pudiendo
ser indianos
qué hacía españa en américa monopolio
absoluto todo lo que voy a entrar de
mercadería era española
y que salía de américa
metales cuánto cuánto salió de américa
81 mil toneladas de plata
en 300 años con ese dinero en españa- se
transformó en el país más fuerte del
mundo es un imperio donde no se ponía el
sol
la plata iba de españa'
a génova o sea como que viene lo dice en
el cuento nazi en américa pasada por
españa y enterraba en génova
en ese tiempo españa fue el país con las
cejas con el ejército más poderoso lo
pagaba la plata de américa
en ese tiempo españa representó a la
iglesia hizo el concilio de trento
carlos quinto que era flamenco que no
hablaban español lo coronaron en bolonia
derrotó a los turcos en lepanto pero
contra los protestantes pero contra los
calvinistas y puso a españa protegida
detrás de los pirineos y en esos 300
años españa
dijo no a mí la revolución política no
me interesa ni me sirve la revolución
religiosa tampoco me interesa la
revolución industrial tampoco me
interesa y américa quedó al margen de
eso
américa durante 300 años vivió ajena a
esa realidad
y cuando cambio
con quien era el conflicto de españa era
en el mar y con quién y primero con los
holandeses después con los ingleses
la armada invencible
hasta que un buen día
el 21 de octubre de 1805 al mediodía un
señor que era manco y tuerto llamado
nelson en una batalla llamada a
trafalgar terminó con la flota española
y con la flota francesa
es una cosa que nadie imaginaba que
alguien podía hacer los barcos de rana
velas como ustedes lo ven en el cine se
ponen frente uno al otro y se tiran con
las bandas y se abordan no este no es
una cosa completamente distinta las paso
por el medio y como apro la popa de los
barcos no hay cañones tiro con los
cañones de los dos lados a voltear los
mástiles y cuando los barcos quedaron
flotando como bañaderas lo cazaron de a
uno pasaron 25 terminaron buena flota
inglaterra así su dueña del mar
como ya tenía un desarrollo industrial
muy fuerte como ya tenía adam smith como
ya tenía lo que como ya tenía un
parlamento democrático como ya tenía una
industria del carbón producía tres veces
más carbón que el resto del planeta como
ya tenía una energía del vapor movía y
movía locomotoras con vapor de agua y
movía telares como por de agua por tanto
que nos trajo un mundo que era cerrado o
era abierto el anterior era cerrado un
monopolio este fue un mundo abierto
absolutamente abierto se hicieron 3.000
kilómetros de ferrocarril se puso el
agua potable en montevideo en 1868 cerca
juegas se trajo el ganado bueno se trajo
las oveja buena se hicieron frigoríficos
se hicieron organizaciones financieras y
nos abrimos al mundo
y llegábamos con lo que producíamos a
cualquier extremo del planeta
y crecimos todos los argentinos
uruguayos brasileros chilenos todos
durante 100 años de estabilidad
económica y de mercados abiertos
fue realmente un mundo que creció en el
mundo atlántico siempre abierto
y por tanto por eso llegaron en 1806 a
maldonado porque habían tenido la
victoria de 1805 intrafamilar si no
hubieran llevado a maldonado
y por eso habían llegado en 1680 a
colonia del sacramento
fundada entre ellos y los portugueses
los portugueses ponían la tropa venían
los ingleses con los barcos bajaban la
mercadería y allí comenzó a funcionar el
único y auténtico mercosur pasaban a
remos de noche la mercadería de colonia
buenos aires
y con que le pagaban y con la plata
negra que venía de potosí
donde estaba la plata
y ese mundo fue un mundo abierto
totalmente abierto hasta cuando hasta el
tratado de versalles después de la
primera guerra mundial
y a partir de ese día el mundo se cerró
de vuelta
en la segunda guerra mundial y hasta
cuando se cerró
y se cerró hasta que terminó el sitio
y cuando termino hay sido primero cayó
el muro de berlín
gorbachov dijo que el comunismo en rusia
terminaba den xiaoping terminó con mao
tse tung y abrió china
y un señor llamado bill gates
nos permitió manejar el tiempo y el
espacio
dice la calle que hablo de las
cuestiones electrónicas y yo tengo una
tableta con botón de pánico este
y de mañana cuando me levanto le mandó
una carta un amigo que vive en nueva
delhi
y me contestó enseguida
con lo que
el tiempo y el espacio los manejamos
como nunca antes el ser humano lo ha
manejado por tanto el mundo es
absolutamente global
abierto y los muchachos de hoy se ponen
la mochila y no precisan ni pasaporte
recorren el mundo
el mundo es abierto de vuelta y en ese
mundo abierto el uruguay tiene que estar
no puede estar encerrado con tres o
cuatro más por más amigos y parientes
que sean porque no le sirve ni a ellos
ni al uruguay
esos cuatro tiempos que son tan
distintos
el primero cerrado el segundo abierto el
tercero cerrado el cuarto abierto tienen
sin embargo algo en común los cuatro
y cuando yo era una reunión donde había
nada más que abogados y contadores que
estudiaban como no pagar impuestos que
eran de todas las razas de todo el mundo
les pregunté y qué es lo que tienen en
común
nadie sabía nada
lo que tienen en común
de que el destino de américa se fija
siempre de afuera
porque somos desde entonces desde que
vino con un hasta ahora vendedores en
materia prima
no somos vendedores de conocimiento
somos vendedores de cobre de hierro de
carne de soja
algún producto lácteo algodón el peruano
es el mejor del mundo somos vendedores
de materias primas
como si cambiáis
por supuesto que con tiempo
las naciones no son más felices porque
sean más grandes y porque sean más ricas
son más felices y tienen más filósofos
más científicos más educadores
el problema el uruguay el número 1 el
50% de los jóvenes
no están en condiciones de entender cómo
funciona el mundo en que viven
el 50 por ciento
precisamos más filósofos más científicos
y más y mejores educadores
e integrarnos al mundo
porque la forma como crecimos cuando
todos los veteranos como yo que tengo
casi 100 años salimos de noche el día de
la nostalgia que lo que estamos
recordando el tiempo de nuestros abuelos
que era tan bueno
y eso lo tenemos que volver hacia él
con decisión con libertad y con un poco
de conocimiento
buena tarde